today I am going to speak about the
future of software development which is
a pretentious topic I work at Microsoft
now as the slide said I am also a
venture capitalist and I invest with a
company and/or a VC firm and Berlin
called blue yard capital we do high-tech
investments and we have done many many
evaluations of very futuristic software
tooling and development companies and so
it's sort of the focus that I have in
blue yard to think about the future of
software development so I'm going to
make some predictions all of which will
be wrong guaranteed but I'm gonna share
them with you and I'm going to tell you
about things that are happening
currently that make them like believable
at least and first I wanted to mention
naresh said he's been trying to get me
to come here forever and it's true and
then he he told me when I got here that
he asked everyone if they had heard of
me and no one raised their hands this
morning so I thought okay I should have
come earlier when I was more relevant so
apologies for that but I'm speaking to
you now from the future so here are my
predictions for the future of software
development software jobs as we know
them whether they be testing or
development will be completely obsolete
what ok he's yelling at me already I
didn't even say anything all software
will be open-source in the future there
will be no closed source commercial
software at all and here's where it gets
really stupid
there will be a blockchain based token
economy it will be built around open
source software and so funding for our
software will be done through buying
into buying shares in open source
software projects and owning shares and
those software projects and the work
that you do will actually be paid to you
by contribution so if you fix an issue
or even submit a valid issue or make a
documentation patch or actually
contribute a feature or add a unit test
you'll actually get paid for that and
that's how as a software developer you
will make
however most of the software that we
developed will not be developed by
humans directly it will be developed by
bots and I was just in Rahul's talk I'm
probably gonna make him mad if he's in
here now because he was talking about AI
and how it can't do anything but I
believe that we are on the cusp of
software being large-scale written by
bots and so it'll either be written by
bots or it will be at least assisted by
artificial intelligence there are a lot
of companies doing this already and
software won't be run on normal servers
anymore it will be run on large-scale
decentralized distributed networks some
of the the software might be running on
your phones or your computers and we
won't really have a concept of separate
computers and then really smart people
will start stepping in and they will
spend their time programmers will spend
their time writing BOTS that can scour
open source software repositories
looking for opportunities to make money
maybe there's a security vulnerability
that is is detected in the wild the
first person who creates the best spot
to go patch all of the open source
software in the world on these
token-based networks will just get rich
from their BOTS going out and doing the
work for them so this is what it looks
like in the future in my crazy vision of
the future now of course probably like I
said none of this is going to happen as
I said it but I want to talk to you
about what's happening now that makes
some of these things believable and not
just far off in the future but
potentially even kind of close in the
near future so in my my tour through the
land of investment and VC it's kind of
funny like you know you start out being
a person who's carrying around martin
fowler's refactoring book yelling at
people about code quality and unit
testing and somehow i've worked myself
into this position where i'm investing
in companies and I'm meeting companies
that are doing things like 3d printing
vehicles that are autonomous run by a I
literally 3d printing buses that go
around
emphases and deliver people with no
drivers I don't know how that happened
but it feels to me like that happened
very suddenly because I remember a time
very recently when this sort of a story
seemed crazy like does anyone remember
when the announcement came out I think
it was on April Fool's Day in 2013 there
was an announcement about how Amazon was
going to start investigating drone
delivery and right now that seems like
okay obviously right but then people
thought it was a joke and I'm actually
not sure today whether it was a joke do
you remember thinking that I people
didn't know right is this a joke RIT has
Bezos gone crazy no that's actually
totally possible today it's not
happening yet at least on large-scale
but it's possible 3d printed rocket
engines that's another one I saw at a
pitch day it's actually true not only
that 3d printed satellites that can be
launched into space affordably
affordably with open-source operating
systems all at a price that I can
actually afford today so I know the
people that I can contact and say give
me a satellite 3d print me a rocket
engine shoot it into space and I'm going
to run my custom Android code on it this
is possible today for me even simple
things like voice recognition you know
when I was a kid this was the stuff that
you saw in sci-fi and now they're
they're here I mean my phone is spying
on us right now and yours is too it's
amazing some news that came out of
Microsoft and just like kind of a boring
blog post from the marketing team at
Microsoft that the farms the most
important crops of the future will be
the data and the knowledge harvested by
autonomous drones
that's just so strange and it's actually
happening speaking of drones here's
something that's happened to our society
we have created a bunch of androids that
are walking the streets and there they
no longer are autonomous themselves
they're being controlled by these little
devices and everyone has one here's the
weird futuristic if you
turistic thing about this like no one
ever knew when I was a kid we would all
have flashlights all the time
everyone has a camera and everyone has a
flashlight in their pocket but we have
we have this and and this is a really
relevant picture and an important piece
of what the future could look like
because through stupid things like games
with colored blocks and other nonsense
you know tik-tok videos and stuff we
have changed fundamentally society and
people's ability to concentrate and
ability to just be okay being in the
world by themselves this is not a
positive thing I don't think maybe it is
I don't know people are pretty bad but
you know if this shows that we have
through fairly trivial combinations of
Technology fundamentally changed human
behavior pretty much all over the world
and this has happened in the last 11
years since the smartphone came out so
all of these advances are happening and
this is me as a venture capitalist now
going around from company to company and
pitch day to pitch day and I'm thinking
we can 3d print autonomous buses but
what are we doing for ourselves as
software developers it's kind of
frustrating so how many of you work in
one of these environments like an
object-oriented programming language
some of you might have been doing this
for years right like when I lived in
India in 2002 I was hiring people to do
Java development and and I sort of
infamously put small talk as a
requirement on the on the job posting so
that I could get the smart Java
developers because they also knew small
talk it was only three people but it
worked maybe one of them is here no no
so this this cutting edge technology
that you are still heavily invested in
is based on the work of these two people
anyone know who these are someone does
for sure yes so these are the creators
of Simula and this was created in 1965
object-oriented programming the the
pervasive paradigm today for software
software development was created in 1965
this is what Simula code looks like now
you don't need to actually be able to
read this but look at the list on the
right all of these things that exist in
Simula they're still sort of considered
modern today it's amazing isn't it it's
it's embarrassing 1965 has was anyone
born in 1965 in the room one person no -
maybe I don't know I'm not gonna point
at you because you're at the back but
you know so before most of us were born
programming languages already that did
what the majority of us are using today
and still learning about and still
thinking about as as modern now the cool
people in the room of course they've
moved on to the future which is
functional programming right anyone
doing functional programming so you're
the cool ones and you're in the future
it's only three people here so no one
should feel bad this is my passion and
software development when I'm actually
programming which is almost never
unfortunately any more
I love Haskell you should all learn
Haskell that's the takeaway from the
talk thank you very much
this stuff was invented in the 50s this
is even older so this is John McCarthy
60 years ago who created Lisp and
closure which is one of the coolest
functional programming languages right
now is a Lisp so Wow we have not really
done anything in the last 50 or 60 years
it's embarrassing isn't it so how about
this anyone interested in serverless
computing or containers orchestration
that kind of stuff yes of course you are
you don't have to raise your hands sorry
anyone ever looked at Erlang so early or
elixir in the 1980s was basically doing
what we're all trying to get kubernetes
and docker and micro services to do now
but it was doing it better than any of
us have achieved so far with kubernetes
Dockers and doctor and micro services
and all the other junk so I do encourage
you to look at Erlang and OTP and the
system that was created there it's
pretty amazing
but 1980s
so you know that's at least 10 years ago
I'm not very good at math because I'm a
music major but you understand
probably here in an agile conference
many of you have you have seen a chart
like this before the standish chaos
report standish chaos report is run by
the Standish Group something like
annually they go out and they do surveys
of large scale projects of big
enterprise organizations and one of the
takeaways from it that is most often
cited is project success rates and so
here and by the way some of you are
thinking Stan just is garbage and you
know it's debunked and whatever you
might be you might be right but I doubt
you'll disagree with their findings on
this so here's the 2012 results for
project success basically you've got 43%
challenged 18 percent failed and then 39
percent successful so challenged means
significantly over time or over budget
and/or over budget and failed means just
cancelled so I would say all of those
equal failed you know I wouldn't I
wouldn't call any of those successful
for sure but I just say the whole thing
is red there on the right that's pretty
embarrassing now this is 2012 so of
course it's 2019 so obviously we've
gotten a lot better by now right
no we have not if you if you graph the
results over the years it just sort of
looks like this you can't see any kind
of trend basically we suck we have
always sucked and we're always going to
suck that's what Standish tells us you
don't need to look at the report anymore
this is what it's always going to say
it's sad
well of course nothing's changed we're
still using technology and approaches
that we started in the 50s and 60s and I
think it's because our intelligence and
arrogance get in the way we think well
programmers and testers will never be
replaced
because these are creative activities
and computers can't do creative things
they can just just do rote automation
for example this this is this is created
by a computer so and
you can go too deep dream generator com2
see a bunch of these things again the
last few years this kind of stuff comes
out I would argue that this is creative
by some definition and if it's not you
can't tell that it's not it would be
pretty impossible for anyone to
determine whether a person created this
or computer and I didn't plug in my
sound but computers are generating songs
so if you if you look up daddy's car
here there's a whole field of music
generation that's going on and I think
this is one of the most interesting
examples of it daddy's car is a pop tune
that's supposed to sound like the
Beatles and it really kind of
realistically could be a Beatles song or
at least like a King Crimson song it's
kind of amazing so hey I guess I guess
computers can actually do creative
things that's kind of scary I would bet
that that if you go through some of the
stuff that you'll find online and deep
dream generator as I said and then music
generation you will not be able to tell
which things are created by computers
and which things are created by people
anymore in some cases also a bunch of
work being done on poetry generation and
you know people create some pretty bad
poetry so that's an easy one an easy one
I guess but we're at a nexus now there's
a bunch of stuff I think and I say this
from scouring the world looking for
bleeding edge software development
tooling teams and people taking software
development and operations to the next
level there's a bunch of stuff that's
coming together that makes new things
possible that weren't possible until a
few years ago until GPUs came along and
FPGAs and other ways of doing
acceleration for example to speed up
machine learning and the list of things
includes the fact that instead of having
you know CVS and subversion repositories
that we install inside our firewalls we
have these large scale distributed
online collaborative code repositories
we're all pretty used to the fact that
we can use something like get
or one of its clones to work remotely it
doesn't matter where we sit anymore much
of the world's software as open-source
now we have distributed and serverless
computing these democratization of AI
largely through advances in hardware and
speed so things like neural networks
which we had discarded as as a useful
technique after the 80s came back into
full force with deep learning and all
the other related stuff that you see
today and then we have blockchain and
digital economies and you may be sort of
thinking oh my God he's going to talk
about blockchain I will apologize for
that later but you'll see that it's
relevant so looking at some of the
trends that we have now I've heard many
people just today say the word micro
service thank you Fred George it's sort
of ruined now because it has a name but
micro-service architectures are now
pervasive we're all doing this sort of
work we're all also kind of by default
doing a mutable infrastructure this the
style of deployment that that's at least
the cutting edge for those of us who are
who are there and the the style just in
case you're not familiar with it is with
immutable infrastructure just like
processes in an operating system you
don't upgrade a process you just kill it
and restart it when you deploy with an
immutable infrastructure type system you
destroy the existing servers and you
replace it with new servers that's the
idea right so it's this idea that you
just throw away servers that was not
possible in the 90s because you would
literally have to throw away the server
and today you don't have to do that
because everything is virtualized and
now sped up through systems like docker
so docker basically gives you like
address spaces separate address spaces
where you can put code and an entire
operating system images or at least
partial operating systems and it gives
you a deployment methodology the
immutable infrastructure style that I
was talking about before and then once
you have these docker containers which
are separate address spaces you have
packages
and the ability to manage multiple
processes processes hire process
hierarchies and use orchestration
systems that allow you to set up process
trees that interact with each other then
we have server list computing like AWS
lambda asher etc this is the culmination
of all those things where it we we
figure out that if we agree on some
conventions the whole concept of a
server can just sink down into the
scenery we don't need to think about
servers anymore it's not truly server
list of course because there is a server
somewhere but with server less computing
you don't consider the server doesn't
matter anymore there's just this
distributed fabric on which you deploy
and run your code so it's sort of like
what Sun was peddling back in the 90s
and early 2000s the network is the
computer Sun was a little bit early with
this phrase and in fact the network was
not the computer back then but now it
really sort of is especially as you look
at stuff like serverless computing and
cloud computing in general but
especially service computing it strikes
me that we are building all the layers
and abstractions around an operating
system again that's what's happening now
and that's why some of it smells like
old timey stuff and doesn't really seem
to be so futuristic after all so if
we're building an app building a new
operating system where the network is
the computer you need an OS on top of it
maybe we need some other abstractions to
make things possible so some of the
things that I've come across that I find
interesting one example is a project
called fast Lange which is created by a
friend of mine it's an open source
project that specifies a standard
conventional approach to describing
serverless functions and you can see in
this case it's written in JSON it's kind
of ugly but at least a ubiquitous
language so it gives us a way to say
there are functions that exist out on
the inner
what if we had a standardized way to
describe how we interface with them not
just to describe but to actually call
them
that's what fast Ling is and the
workflow is basically any any provider
whether it be your own thing that you
run in a docker container or it be a
juror functions or AWS lambda could
implement this and then you could think
of the entire Internet as a surface on
which you could call things in a
standardized fashion and it's a nice
simple approach so imagine if you took
this to the next level you're you're
specifying types for all of these
functions that exist in serverless
fashion all over the internet that gives
you the ability to in a strongly typed
manner know what the inputs and outputs
potential exception modes are allow you
to specify whether or not there are side
effects of the functions it gives you
the ability then to pipeline in the same
way that you would with UNIX processes
or functional programming functions on
the Internet and that's what we're
thinking about like building abstract
building an iOS across the network right
so imagine what would be possible there
you could save that this thing running
over here on here okuu calls this other
thing and pipes its output to this other
thing that's running on AWS lambda and
this other thing gets called on Azure
and if they were co-located if you had
these ubiquitous type definitions and
you knew which things were idempotent
for example you could even do things
like optimize on servers so
transparently so there would be no
network round-trips so you can do all
sorts of interesting things with this
this network OS that we're in the
process of building if we can only get
together on some conventions and
standards and the people who did fast
laying are working on something called
standard libe and if any of you are C
programmers or testers that have worked
in in a C orient environment you would
recognize the spelling of standard live
is supposed to look like the C standard
library and the concept is taking you
know if you're a UNIX programmer you
know that there's a standard library
and see you over time learn what all the
functions are they become standard you
know how to do formatted printing and IO
etcetera what if you had a standard
library on the internet with standard
conventions for conventions for calling
the code and for the functions to talk
to each other and you didn't have to
think any more when you wanted to do
common tasks that we all have to do on
the Internet if you think about what you
do on the Internet today if you allow
yourself to view the network as a
computer and us building an OS what you
do on the Internet today is incredibly
primitive and annoying compared to what
you would do if you're writing C code on
Linux or on hp-ux god forbid or
something like that
so I can't make hp-ux jokes anymore
because no one's old enough to have
experienced the pain of it or AIX so and
I can't even say that I can't because
you don't know what I mean
apologies but sometimes you just have to
tell jokes to yourself you know that's
how we get by in life so this is just
another example from standard Live
yep showing you the power if you look at
this line that says let Trax equal you
see what's happening here is there is
automatically a namespace
in standard live called Jacob Lee
because Jacob Lee has deployed code in
that namespace and he has a function
called recommend music it is versioned
it has inputs and outputs you can go
look them up through you know the
standard documentation of the standard
life of the internet and call and it's
all just completely transparent and you
don't think about the location of this
thing it could be on AWS it could be in
someone's data center it could be on
here okuu I think this is a really
powerful thing and it's aspirational
because even this if you if you try to
imagine going back to your workstation
and really writing an app this way you
probably don't believe that it's
possible because it isn't but people are
working on this stuff now so let's talk
about real serverless computing and this
is where I go through the quick Bitcoin
apology or
blockchain apology so a few years ago
there was the crazy hype and I assert
that we were now in the trough of
disillusionment
and I say this from the vantage point of
someone who is a VC who has invested in
a bunch of blockchain related
technologies and also turned down most
of the possible investments in
blockchain related technologies because
they were garbage
absolute garbage in the same way that
most people who say they're doing agile
are actually doing something that's
absolute garbage right
see I tailor this thing to the audience
I only wish I had put some more
offensive stuff in here for you guys but
you know I do what I can so there is
absolutely a foundational change that
can happen if we continue down this path
of the real valuable blockchain stuff
that's going on it is unquestionably a
set of technologies and techniques that
can change the way the internet works in
a good way in a positive way but many of
us will run screaming from it because
we've seen all the trash that's happened
and we've seen all the scam icos that
have happened that will clearly Neville
never amount to anything except for
making someone rich and making a lot of
other people poorer so I'm going to talk
for a minute about what blockchain means
how many of you do you think you
actually describe how a blockchain works
right now
okay good this is the right crowd
because I'm going to do that and if you
could already do it you'd be bored so
what is a blockchain it's kind of silly
actually because we talked about like
blockchain tech and what is your
blockchain strategy a blockchain is a
linked list that's what it is so it's
like saying what's your linked list
strategy you know and maybe they did
that in 80s I don't know or the 70s but
a blockchain is literally a linked list
but it has some interesting properties
and those are
like any linked list every node points
to the previous node but in this case it
points to it by way of a cryptographic
hash so the hash actually is of the
contents of the previous node the
previous node unless it's the root node
also points to its previous node which
means at every step the cryptographic
hash contains every possible value all
the way back down to the root if you
change any value down in the middle of
the tree the hash is invalid and you
literally can't traverse the tree any
more so that's all it is
and when I say hash I mean like you know
a sha hash like the sort of hashing
we're we're all probably familiar with
that's all it is that's what a
blockchain is not very special not very
fancy and and so you know you are now
all blockchain experts at the end of the
presentation by the way I will have one
small link that is easy to remember that
will have links to everything so you're
very welcome to continue to take
pictures of the slides but also know
that I've got a bunch of stuff you can
click on later and read and detail
including a link to this this
presentation that I got this picture
from or sorry this medium post that I
got the picture from that does a great
job of explaining blockchain tech so a
blockchain is a linked list and the
magic of it it is is that it is tamper
proof that's all it is not something
that can actually be distributed across
a network and maintain consistent
consensus and that's where this concept
of proof of work comes in now proof of
work is not the only type of consensus
but it is the one that is built into
Bitcoin proof of work in a nutshell says
basically anytime someone wants to
commit a block into the blockchain so a
node into that linked list they have to
race to answer a very difficult math
question and the math question is set up
so that it is trivial to check whether
it's right and very expensive
computationally to generate it so this
means that you have computers all over
the internet copying this linked list
around getting a broadcast of the
changes that someone wants to make and
all racing to commit that change and
whoever commits the change gets a coin
in the Bitcoin world and and hopefully
that coin is worth something it's worth
a lot less now than it was two years ago
but this is a really stupid thing but
it's incredibly powerful because it
exploits our greed and our desire to
make money so that we race against each
other since there's a financial reward
for calculating this thing we're all
racing to calculate to calculate the
number faster than everyone else which
makes it very very difficult to game the
system unfortunately it has another
effect similar to the zombie thing that
I showed you earlier with the iPhones
that we're just running the processors
like crazy trying to calculate these
numbers were burning up so much energy
we could destroy the planet there are
people who are not idiots that say that
Bitcoin and block and blockchain crypto
currencies could actually be our
civilizations downfall and you can find
this is an old article I'm sad to say
and in this it was talking about using
more power for Bitcoin than the country
of Ireland uses just to generate these
stupid numbers but it's all a race and
the purpose of this race is that it
forces a consensus using incentives and
we're all incentivized to get the coin
so we're all racing to generate this
number and that is really the core of
what makes real blockchain technology
worth exploring and the things that will
survive and blockchain technology are
the ones that exploit that and expand on
it so bitcoin is an is an incentive
based protocol where the incentive is
driven by this it by this stupid
generation of a number imagine if you
could set
something like Bitcoin where the thing
we're all racing to do in order to get
paid is actually valuable to the world
so this is one that I always cite as the
the best example that I've seen and I
invested in this so full disclosure you
cannot invest in it now so I'm not
really selling you anything because it's
closed right now so you can't accuse me
of trying to get you to buy something
yet but I do suggest that you download
this white paper and read it if you have
any interest in this
what file coin is is a replacement for
services like Dropbox onedrive etc for
file sharing that has the potential to
be way better than any centralized
service could ever be and at the same
time would be encrypted end-to-end and
no central player would own the data is
right now if you put your your files and
Dropbox you don't actually know what
they they're gonna do with it you have
to trust them but with file coin they
would be distributed all over the
internet and no one would have control
only the protocol would have control and
instead of doing proof of work they have
created some novel consensus consensus
algorithms and we're not going to get
too deep into them but just to give you
a taste of what they do they have proof
of replication which said which is an
algorithm that is cryptographically
provable that proves that a file that
you have is actually replicated onto
your disks so that you have them and
that it's replicated across the network
and you will be rewarded as a server of
the file for having replicated it
instead of just pointing somewhere else
and then we also have proof of
space-time which proves that you had the
file for a certain amount of time now
this is important because in a
distributed file solution where you're
paying someone to serve up files and and
I should have said this the incentive
here is I request a file from the file
coin network
and you can all broadcast back if you
have the file I can give you that file
and if I get the file from you you get
paid for having transferred it to me
that's the basic idea around around file
coin proof of space/time proves that you
actually had it before I requested it to
avoid the scenario where you could say
oh I have the file and then go get it
from someone else and pass it on so it
proves that you have it there are all
sorts of other things built into the
protocol protocol if you read it about
being close to the source so you're more
likely to actually get paid and to win
the race if you and I are on the same
network and I request the file and you
serve it to me so you can imagine it
gives you this distributed
geographically distributed replicated
encrypted end-to-end file serving and
storage approach where no one has any
ownership you don't have to trust any
central company and potentially based on
the greed of the participants you would
get something from a local network or
something very close even if you're in a
place that isn't normally served by
large cloud vendors it just has to do
with demand
pretty powerful stuff and there are a
number of other protocols that are built
like this that are worth checking out
now when when I said that let's talk
about real Cerberus computing you start
with the blockchain stuff and then you
move to aetherium have you heard of
aetherium anyone yeah a few or maybe
third of the people so aetherium is
another one of the crypto currencies
that has gone like this in price and
when I first started learning about
aetherium I thought okay it's a crypto
currency it's somehow better than
Bitcoin I'm not sure how and then I
talked to some of the people who were
core developers on aetherium and they
said it's a distributed virtual machine
and that's kind of where it stopped and
for a while is really hard to understand
how but the idea actually is that with
aetherium you can create code deploy it
into the the blockchain and the
blockchain is just this ledger
you know there's linked listing so it's
a terrible distributed slow database
that runs across the world
you deploy your code into it because
it's a blockchain your code is tamper
proof you know that it's safe you
actually can never change the code the
only way to deploy more code is
immutable infrastructure basically you
have to create new versions and the and
the code runs they call it a contract so
I'm going to show you what it looks like
here here is an example program and
we're not going to go line by line
through it but you can see this is real
code that someone is programmed in a
language that sort of looks like
JavaScript there are multiple languages
that you can write and compile into the
distributed virtual machine of aetherium
this is called solidity it's the default
language from aetherium but it actually
is a virtual machine and you can really
write code that runs in it it's code
that will run slower than any code
you've ever run and it will access a
database that is the world's slowest
database but it will be tamper proof
encrypted end-to-end it will you can
never turn it off which has an
interesting property because as long as
the decentralized list of computers on
the internet running aetherium is still
up or that some are still up your code
will still be there but we have now a
virtual machine oh and I left out an
interesting thing it's kind of like
Haskell it's very very hard to do IO and
only people who have ever tried Haskell
will understand that joke but it is
almost impossible to do anything outside
of the virtual machine so to deal with
that there are a bunch of new
technologies that are coming layering on
top of this VM and guess what just like
we're doing in serverless we're building
an OS piece-by-piece and some of the
examples of that our file coin as I
talked about building a distributed file
system Zeppelin os handles a bunch of
things for package management - Process
Management but we're actually building
what I believe could eventually be a
usable distributed runtime where there
is actually no server there is this
abstract concept of a server of course
it's running on computers but there will
never actually be a server behind this
and that's why I say real distributed
computing a real serverless computing
now an interesting property of all of
these blockchain projects is they are
all 100% open-source the ones that are
not open-source are the ones you should
never use because you have to be able to
remove trust of individuals and trust
the protocols so it's sort of inherent
in the model of blockchain projects that
if they are that they have to be open
source so that you don't have to trust
them you need to be able to audit how
they work now because they're all open
source it means that the software itself
is not the valuable thing and this is
what contributes to what I was saying
earlier one of the things that
contributes to what I was saying earlier
about all software potentially being
open source in the future if you look at
on the right here this article you see
that when file coin did its ICO it
raised 257 million dollars in an hour or
two hours something like that so that
company is now well funded and what
they're going to do is for the rest of
their existence they'll be writing
nothing but open source software and
they're incentivized
to write very high quality open source
software because people have to trust
the code and they have to trust the
protocols and the value is in the
network they're creating with these
tokens and and the consensus mechanisms
and all of this stuff the blockchain
that's where the value is we all just
buy into the network we don't buy the
software anymore so I think that
software is already becoming primarily
open-source now I live in a little
bubble of nerds that have been doing
open-source software since the 90s and
before but you can see a bunch of stats
and it probably rings true to you now
that almost all companies are relying on
open source software I mean even the the
very famously closed source iOS is built
on an open source base a bunch of the
stuff in your phone no matter what phone
you're using is open source I have a
team at work
where
we're doing developer relations for
various audience communities and one of
them is open source and in that audience
I have to actually explain to people at
Microsoft no I don't mean people using
open source software because that's
everyone now and you know Microsoft is
still catching up with that notion but I
mean people actually creating open
source software that is now a viable
segment of the population that we should
be thinking about catering to as a
company because so many people are
writing open source so because all
software is and will be open-source we
need different funding models for open
source and you know there are there's
the obvious old one where companies
sponsor it
you know like basically popularized by
Red Hat and company back in the early
com Bubble days of open source then you
have the ICO model where people are
building blockchain based stuff and it
networks have the value and then you
have a Wi-Fi pop-up let's see an
interesting project that is coming out
of Berlin called OS coin is actually the
implementation of this blockchain based
protocol what they're trying to do now
is completely reimagine and re-implement
open source software as an
incentive-based protocol so that you
would actually be paid for things like
creating issues closing issues
contributing to documentation etc now
because so much software is open-source
we have popularized through github the
concept of pull requests and this leads
to the next major change the pull
request as we all get used to it it
starts to not really matter where we sit
anymore you know it used to really
matter more and it may be this is heresy
and an agile conference but I might be
at home I might be on an island
somewhere I can submit code make a pull
request people can make comments and
it's sort of interesting you realize
after a while that when you're looking
at a pull request and people are making
comments on your code
you don't really know if it's a person
behind that anymore I mean it might be a
name you don't recognize on a large team
that can very often be the case or it
could be a name you do recognize it
could be at chat on github which is me
but you don't know that I actually did
it I might have set up a script that
looks for all pull requests and just
types lol on part of your code for
example which I have done before to my
team so how do we know if it's a person
we're interacting with we don't anymore
and that's really cool and the first the
first implementation of this that I saw
that really excited me was a company
called sneak and what they do is
actually not very intelligent but it
feels really intelligent they look for
vulnerabilities to open-source libraries
as they're reported on the internet and
then they scan your repositories to see
if you depend on those open-source
libraries if you do they automate the
creation of a pull request with a patch
that just upgrades to the safe version
and links back to the disclosure of the
security vulnerability and that's it and
the cool thing about that is when I saw
this the first time I realized I don't
like code that changes my code because I
don't trust it but if code submits a
pull request and I can review it just
like it's a human that's pretty cool
actually I can see the diff you know
probably won't change the code if I
comment on it you know if I give it
suggestions but I realized then that
this pull request model is extremely
powerful for the future of us being able
to automate the creation of code and the
modification of code and it's really
interesting to think about where that
can go there are a bunch of teams
working on this now
and as machine learning speeds up
further through acceleration GPUs FPGAs
and perhaps stuff like quantum computing
if that pans out and it's pretty close
potentially maybe we don't know actually
but it could be really close if it does
everything's different it means that we
can start doing things like automating
through AI the creation of our AI models
using machine learning to create machine
learning to create machine learning and
if we can do that we're creating
programs now that we already do it right
we don't write all the code in these
apps that use ml the machine is writing
the code we're training the code
the program is evolve so we're already
sort of there it's not even crazy to say
that we might get to a point someday
where the machines can code themselves
because they're doing it in your phone
and on my computer right now all the
time so maybe someday we'll just train
software like dogs and we won't write
code anymore at all maybe you know
quantum computing happens that raises
all sorts of other weird concerns like
well how do we audit that code how do we
make sure that it's HIPAA compliant you
know how do we know that it's not biased
against people there's whole fields of
study to figure out whether code is
biased you know does it only recognize
white people's faces that's
unfortunately something that exists and
in the wild and because we have these
massive code repositories like github
for the first time in history it gives
us centralized dumps of code and
activity around code that we can analyze
as huge corpuses Corp I it doesn't
matter
of data that allow us to build models
machine learning models the same way we
would over natural language there are
projects that are now trying to look at
all the world's code and turn it into a
common language so Babel Fish is an
example of that and then researchers who
are taking these common representations
and turning them into semantic
representations that allow us to reason
over them and here's the best pointer to
all this stuff that you might find ml
for code github I oh this is a colleague
of mine but he's he's a researcher and
he's just catalyzed cataloging the
world's efforts in ml driven code
creation it's not just code though what
about repository activity think about
all of the repositories that you've
worked
the last couple of years every commit
every comment every revert it's a mass
of interesting information this is
actually from 2009 or 2008 Michael
feathers wrote a really interesting
article about just analyzing file churn
versus complexity and it's amazing the
intelligence quote-unquote that comes
out of stupid and analyses like this but
think about all the things you can do if
you you look at the activity around code
and you have a semantic representation
all of these things are already possible
and researchers are working on it one of
my favorite examples is a team in Israel
called Co dota and you can actually play
with the examples on their website
they've downloaded all the source code
from github they are out of Technion
University in Israel the the lead is a
guy named Iran yaha who has been doing
program synthesis machine learning work
for 15 years or something like way back
when people thought he was insane but
the results are remarkable it looks like
magic some of the things you can do it's
like code completion of an entire app in
some cases which he admits would be
stupid but is possible and it's not just
code you can automate automated testing
why would we even create user interfaces
anymore what about the data behind stuff
like performance and site reliability
engineering so much data flowing through
these things when there's an outage do
you still go look at graphs and numbers
and decide which things to restart and
create more of there's so many things
that we can do all based on this nexus
of things that have changed so you're
probably not going to go back and throw
away all your code after watching this
talk I might actually but not because of
the talk so what do we do now well I
think the first thing is to realize that
we need to do something different and as
an industry at least allow ourselves to
to think more ambitiously than we have
been thinking
we haven't been applying all these in
credible advances that we are to stuff
like self-driving cars to our own worlds
so let's do that open source or die that
is my message I think companies that are
trying to build closed source software
they're destined to fail and it's not a
zero to one switch that you can make
overnight but whether it's internal
software or software that you're selling
need you should think about how to open
source your software and also how to use
as much open source software as makes
sense for you something that will apply
to all of you in order to be ready for
this crazy future no matter which one
happens it is universally true that
decoupling will be a good thing for you
to do because if it turns out you should
throw away large swaths of what you
exist of your code assets the best case
is that you have clear interfaces
between them and that the parts that you
will keep are well separated and then
dive into this blockchain stuff
especially here in the trough of
disillusionment because if you look at
this the innovation curve the Gartner
curve you'll see that if you're
successfully betting at the right time
in the trough of disillusionment then
you stand to gain a lot as it rises back
up so I say now is actually the time to
really learn about blockchain crypto
currencies all those sorts of
technologies because the world has lost
faith in them but we've also learned a
bunch of lessons about things that don't
work and then I think every developer
now actually has to do machine learning
somehow you need to at least get machine
learning literate because every problem
might be a machine learning problem in
the near future or today so if you don't
think that that's your realm it's sort
of like someone saying well I don't need
to learn object-oriented programming or
I don't need to learn about the web or
about mobile development kind of sounds
like Microsoft and the 90s doesn't it
but they're in the 2000s you will get
left behind if you don't know how this
stuff works and it's really important to
and that's me this is my link so check
the link it's got all sorts of links to
all the stuff that I've lost over and
thank you very much for your time
[Applause]